pas un mot à quiconque
tout ça est secret d'état j'ai vu assez
d'officier pour la journée j'ai bien
peur d'être également un officier armées
polonaises je vais tenter ma chaise
on
ne peut pas gagner tout seul il nous
faut le soutien des angles soeur winston
churchill jan novak qui nous vient de
varsovie 1 courir
l'otage est de convaincre bord de
commencer un soulèvement lui même
cet instant précis de ces cinq années de
guerre sanglante
l'avenir de la pologne dépend de vous
oui ce satané pour qui
ils ont comme lui il me recherche
il y a des microfilms dans le manche du
blaireau si quelque chose arrive
détruisez les d'abord je dois partir
tout de suite peut-être que nous nous
reverrons j'espère il faut attendre on
ne peut pas commencer sans le soutien
des prix tels certainement pas avant que
les soviétiques nous envahissent
dacia sandero
j'ai surpris
[Musique]